I'm so excited because the book will pre
launch next week so it's been a long
road and i'm so excited hopefully you
can see the huge smile and energy coming
from me today after all the work we are
finally almost ready to pre launch the
book and hopefully by the time this time
next week when this video comes out the
page will be live for you to be able to
pre-order my box right now I'm just
going to the final stages of what you
get for each copy of the book my
publisher and Bryan Holaday have given
me some good feedback on what to include
you guys give me some good feedback and
we're finally almost there and just so
excited so grateful that's my only
announcement for this video and I get to
talk about the book is about next week
to which has been insane that we've done
59 video is talking about the book and
you still don't know what my book is
about so thank you for sticking around
for this over a year series next week
I'll talk about the book I'll talk with
the pre-orders so excited stay tuned so
let's get to the questions you guys had
from last week first up is much i love
the rent on why you put out so much
content totally passionate and inspired
hashtag believe thank you much yeah i
went on a bit of a rant last week about
why i put out the content and people
saying i should do only one a week or or
slow it down I get that question a lot
from people and it was great that I had
the opportunity to be able to answer it
in in the video what I'm also going to
do now is separate that video out and
just release it on its own and then link
it up for anybody who asked me that
question or anybody who posts you pose
too much anybody who says you should
only do once a week or whatever they're
going to get a link to that video and
they can watch the rant so much thank
you for calling it out so that other
people also benefit from seen it next up
is a no I certainly believe in the auto
by thing there are some people that
would support by buying their stuff no
matter what and sometimes I only have to
see hear or read something from someone
once for me to support him or her it's a
super interesting comment and that came
up in last video and a good lesson for
you as an entrepreneur how do you built
up enough equity enough
enough of an audience so that they will
buy from you no matter what you put out
and it's it's part of branding right so
if I'm buying from whole foods I expect
the food to be of a certain quality
right of the animals are treated
ethically the you know there's not
chemicals in the ingredients and so I
don't have to check the label of every
product because it's coming from whole
foods right when i go to costco i'm
expecting to get a deal right i'm
expected to be brand-name stuff good
quality and i'm going to get a deal it's
not one hundred percent of the time but
you know i don't have to price check
other stores and i don't have to read
all the reviews on these products as
much if i'm buying it from costco
because there's that brand reputation
built up and so you know for you what's
the brand that you've built up do people
know you for a certain thing have you
built up enough equity and trust that
people would auto buy your book your
service your product as soon as it came
out because they know and they like you
and if not then you've got some work to
do I'm building your personal brand next
up is Elvis love your vids Evan thank
you Elvis can you make one of us Steve I
he is a truly inspiring person lots of
interviews to dig up content thanks for
everything man so Elvis I took this one
because we've already done Steve I've so
you can go check it out and for those of
you who are leaving comments requesting
people I'd encourage you to go actually
like type in Steve I top ten rules for
success or even just Steve I you'll
probably show up we've done a lot of
these videos are ready and i love the
comments coming in but part of part of
it too for you guys is taking some
accountability in doing a little bit of
work like it doesn't take a lot of work
to see if we've already done that person
or not before and you should be out
doing a little bit of research on your
own so we've already done it and second
of all for you guys watching my team
usually picks up the comments about the
top 10 videos the best place to leave it
if you want to get the response is on
the top 10 videos themselves not in the
book video but i wanted to take this one
for that little bit of a shout out so
thank you guys to the question next up
elite tahiti rights in will your book be
available on kindle yep it will be
available on kindle it'll be a ebook
will have a deluxe ebook version and i
believe
regular ebook version i guess the deluxe
one will have more video content and
some bonuses included as well but that
was one of the earlier conversations
should we have an e-book should we have
a audiobook version you guys said you
really wanted it so the publisher is
going to make it and now we need to
deliver for them next up is Natalie I
start my morning listening to your
videos great start to my business day
thank you nightly I really appreciate
that and and I take it as a there's a
responsibility for me to or like I feel
the not not just like the obligation to
make stuff for you guys but the a
credible gratitude that you guys have me
as part of your daily routine and and
when we're making the videos you know
when i'm reviewing it i want to make
something that will make you guys proud
to write i make something that i love
but i know that lots of people are
consuming this and so i want to be able
to make something that that you guys are
going to love find impact from get value
from want to share have have some kind
of change happen in your life your
business and I think sometimes it's hard
for an entrepreneur to see the impact
that they're having and especially for
the team of the entrepreneur to see the
impact on their having but if you start
out with that as an intention so
whatever product or service you're
selling if you start in the design of
that product or service with the
intention that somebody's going to use
it consistently they're going to come
back to it consistently not just trying
to have some kind of one off sale but
you care about the lifetime value of
that person interacting with you then
you design your products and services in
a different way or I think a lot of
people are just trying to make that
quick sale and they don't care about the
repeat business of the lifetime viagra
how much impact they're actually having
you know the the classic example is the
the car salesman who sees the next
person coming in and say well that that
guy there that's my next three suits
right like you're thinking about
yourself what you can buy from it the
value that you get without really
actually caring about that person and
making a relationship and giving them
the thing that's best for them even that
may mean send them to a different
dealership how many car sales people
would send somebody to a different
dealership because it was the right
thing for that client right but that
wins you loyalty that gets you referrals
that's the best interest of the parties
involved and so when you guys are
videos I take that as a responsibility
to try to do the thing that's not just
best for me what's going to get me a ton
of use but the impact that will have on
your life and trying to create
meaningful content so I'm glad that
that's coming through I'm honored that
I'm part of your morning routine and
really thank you for that comment next
up is Eric I really hope to be an
affiliate for your book I believe in you
and I'm stoked about the book much
appreciated Eric I don't know what kind
of affiliate options there are I don't
own the book right it's going through my
publisher penguin Random House and so
whatever typical affiliate offers are
available through big publishers I guess
that will be available definitely
through amazon I don't know if those
other links where you can be an
affiliate if you do start doing that let
me know if there are other options let
me know too i'd love to be able to kind
of encourage that and help spread the
word but i'm not able to kind of sell it
myself and give you my own affiliate
link because it's going through the
major publishers so if any of you guys
are booked affiliate and are having
success i'd love to hear from you love
to connect with you I love ideas on how
I might be able to encourage you and
help you and doing the efforts that you
guys are doing to help promote books
haven't really thought too much about
affiliate marketing in the promotion of
my book in the series so if you guys
have resources knowledge to share link
it up below and looking forward to
connecting with you next up is Steven
being completely honest I love your
stuff now but I have to admit at one
point I was not a fan of the channel and
had unsubscribed but your stuff grew in
quality to me and was so good I could
not deny you thanks all the best in your
future endeavors Thank You Steven I
appreciate the brutal honesty right I
don't want people around me just saying
oh good job it was great you know all
only the positive stuff obviously I love
that but much more important for me as a
constructive criticism I don't always
agree with the criticism I don't always
make changes base of it but as an
entrepreneur on yourself with yes men
who are just always filling you up where
you want to know how you can improve and
how you can get better I agree to I
think the quality has gotten better one
I feel like I've gotten better on camera
if you look at me vs I don't know when
you subscribe 6 months ago a year ago
two years ago I've gotten better on
camera it's making me much more easy to
digest and consume
pair to where I was before I think our
quality standards have gotten better how
we picked the videos has gotten better
like we're learning how to do this right
nobody else is doing this so we're
paving the way and we're making mistakes
and we're figuring out the recipe and so
every time we try something that makes
us a little bit better and so I think
our quality has gone up significantly
every month I think our quality goes up
significantly I appreciate the honesty
appreciate you being willing to share
that welcome back on board it's great to
have you and hopefully we keep you for a
long time next up is pure etawah who
wrote in the say it would be cool if you
could do a meetup to not only get to
meet you but this awesome community of
like-minded aspiring entrepreneurs I
agree I mean one of my favorite things
to do when traveling is meeting with
entrepreneurs if you guys around my
newsletter list anytime I travel to a
certain city I will let people know from
that city hey I'm coming to New York k
and coming to Chicago hey and coming to
wherever I'd love to be able to grab a
coffee usually it's around some other
thing I'm presenting somewhere have some
meetings and I try to cram as much stuff
especially if I'm not traveling with
Nina and Hayden I don't like the
downtime like I can always work from
home when i'm out i want to be impactful
or i don't want to make the best use of
those 24 or 48 hours whatever it is and
i'm away for and so I love be able to
connect with you guys and so again if
you're not on the newsletter list you
can get there for when I might be coming
to your city I do meetups in Toronto for
youtubers we had one on the weekend to
try to help local aspiring youtubers or
you know already having their channel to
get to be bigger to learn from me but
also to meet each other and have a
connection group to build you know
bounce ideas off of for the book I
really wanted to do a campaign I'll
probably talk about this a little bit
more next week but I wanted to do a
campaign based on cities where if a
certain city bought a certain number of
books then i would go to that city and
maybe film my entire set with them for
that week and meet them and have coffee
and all of this stuff it's proving to be
a little bit difficult to track based on
what the publisher can give me in terms
of data so I if I'm going to do I have
to find another way but I love the idea
be able to come to different cities as
part of the book tour to meet you guys
to give you shout outs on the channel
and if you guys meet each other to you
know every time I go into a city and met
the local entrepreneurs there's always
been like lasting connections between
the people who came out and it's great
to have other people to share your ideas
with apart from just meeting me for that
you know 30 minutes that I showed up at
a starbucks now you have like new
friends in a big city that you can
connect with and continue to share ideas
with next up is Kim I want that shirt
Evan Kim is referring to my shirt from
last week it wasn't this one it's the
one that has all the words like
entrepreneur rebel all a bunch of words
the most popular features that I where
I've actually linked up in the
description of all the new videos so
it's a campaign with teespring that you
guys can pick your size if you want this
belief shirt or you want the one with
the the different words we call that one
the rebel shirt you can click click it
up there link it and if you guys
actually buy it take a picture of it or
take a video with it let me know I want
to see it i might share it too i'd love
to see more believe out there you guys
spreading it to you know your friends
and your community on your channels so
if you guys do end up buying it take a
picture let me know I want to see so
wrap it up there thank you guys so much
for watching super excited again about
next week and the launch of the
pre-order campaign we've got a lot of
work to do and hopefully hopefully
hopefully we're ready in time I love to
know what you guys think any other
questions about about the book about the
book writing process about my book other
questions that you may have leave it in
the comments below and I will do my best
to answer it for you on next week's
video thank you again for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon